oh
yes
yes the state is great brilliant
physical performer an absolute pleasure
to work with him
ah the one two
it's so good i make a lot of movies so
at some point
i'm gonna be injured i just want you to
just poke as many holes and this as you
can see let's hope it's really bad
welcome that's right it's me this time
to another episode of stuntmen react and
today we have one of the greatest of all
time the legend himself scott atkins
sitting next to me on the couch here i
cannot think of a person better
qualified to talk about punching and
kicking i've done a lot of punching and
kicking in my time
it seemed like a good idea when i was
12.
my lower back is like you fought
you should have been an accountant
damn you so scott is going to break down
some of the fights that he's been in as
well some of the iconic fights from the
silver screen let's have a look at some
of these clips
expendables too two angry british men
fight each other he's not going to be
british in this
make him russian
[Music]
this is a bit too silhouette for my
liking but it does it looks great but
then sometimes you want to make sure
that you can see everything that's going
on like sometimes it's nice to have the
two characters that are fighting look
drastically different so your eye
doesn't need to adjust to who's who
the state is great brilliant physical
performer an absolute pleasure to work
with him you're working with the pro so
we get through the scenes really quick
we don't need that many takes so it's
like jason statham at least starting out
didn't strike me as like a martial
artist per se but he just ended up
becoming such an action staple well he's
done martial arts in the past but i
think when he started doing the
transporter really started training a
bit more in it and you know going down
the action route
yeah i was pretty chuffed when i saw
that now when you are working in your
fight scenes do you ever take
inspiration from cartoons you ever take
inspirations from video games what other
sources outside of you know physicality
do you reach out to to take your
inspiration from i can't say that i get
inspired by cartoons actually there was
one cartoon clip where they're
completely ripped off a fight that i did
in undisputed too it's the exact same
fight signals that was pretty cool i
mean they say that imitation is the
highest form of flattery right so
whenever it happens it's always good for
me it's the 80s hong kong action that's
where i get the inspiration from where
you're getting specific angles of the
fist coming to the camera and then go
wide for the guy to do the big flip and
land in the table and smash when you're
looking at the sort of earlier hong kong
stuff the cameras sat back we're putting
the performers on the screen we're
seeing the moves themselves and the
combos and the sequences tend to be
longer and that puts the onus on the
performer side at that point because
it's like you need to sell this sequence
it's something that you start to lose
when you start to push against like ah
let's just cut and get around that's why
they're cut because you're working with
people that can't do it in a static
shot there's a lot of actors now that
are doing action films and i've got
nothing but respect for it when i see
that they've put the effort and people
like keanu reeves that didn't
necessarily start out in in the world of
stunts but you can see the effort that
he puts into the john wheat films and he
turns up at the gym and he trains hard
with the stunt guys and he knows exactly
what to do and now he's as good as the
other stunt guys and that's what it's
all about it's just about turning up
putting the effort in and you'll get
better you know unless you've got two
left feet like this guy
i feel like we've come away from the
shaky cam yeah quick edit crossing the
line and back again like that oh god
thank god
it's so terrible that's one of the
reasons why i started my show art of
action so i could put an end to that
nonsense
so people can understand why you
shouldn't do this
in my opinion this is one of the top
fights i've seen on film with you i
don't know if you guys are just pushing
yourselves a little bit harder or if
it's just one of those things where
everything comes together perfectly but
something about this fight scene stands
out to me is just being elevated
i'm there i'm in the movie and i find
out i'm going to beat up both tony jar
and eco aways at the same time i'm going
oh my god
is it my birthday is it christmas
i felt bad for eco because at least tony
comes back and kicks my ass at the end
but you know he's just such a nice
humble guy that he's like oh you know
i'm here to serve the story and that's
what's great because a lot of action
guys they can get a bit of an ego you
don't want to lose on screen because
your fans don't want to see you lose on
screen and i understand why it's a thing
because i've had fans you know
facebooking me going why are you losing
i'm upset about it because i'm an actor
this kick right here oh man yeah
that was just a case of right i'm going
to jump up and you're going to kick me
as hard as you can ah the one two
it's so good
oh was that you that was me yeah oh
oh yes
[Music]
i'm landing on a pad i'm not concrete
but yeah it's a pretty good move can you
imagine actually pulling that off in a
real fight
[Laughter]
when people see a film like this it's
got all the top martial artists in
you're going to compare it to ip man and
john wick and all the rest of it we so
much wanted to work with each other that
we didn't really have a big budget so we
had a very finite amount of shooting
days so this fight i think was done in
two days wow whereas the ip-man fight
was seven days so you can see that yeah
that's crazy it's just a quicker pace
but you know we did the best we could
did you know that we usually film for at
least two hours just to make a 15 minute
react episode we do that to deliver the
best top tier reactions and breakdowns
that we can every single week but that
means that sometimes entire scenes don't
make the cut sorry guardians of gahool
we've tried thanks to your comments
encouraging us to make longer episodes
we're gonna start releasing extended
cuts on quarterdigital.com
starting this week with scott atkins now
you'll be able to see the content we
can't include on youtube for fear of
angering the algorithm that means more
raw reactions more rants more scenes too
spicy for work we've got a free two-week
trial to dip your toes into and we've
even got newly updated ios and android
apps so if you want to check it out and
maybe stick around for some of our
exclusive content like son of a dungeon
or functional filmmaking head on over to
quarterdigital.com or download the app
to get started let's get back to the
episode we went hard on one of your
fight scenes with michael j white who
gave you a little ribbon yeah i wanted
to offer up the opportunity for you to
do the same to one of my questions
so this is hope it's really bad this is
nerf john wick and i just want you if
you can just poke as many holes in this
as you can just go to town this time
i'll be right there with you bud okay
it's good
oh
see i like the way you're turning the
camera to accentuate the action you're
just searching for compliments
it's good stuff
that's good stuff that was making me
feel so good
[Music]
what would have been nice there was a
little jolt or something maybe gone a
bit closer and then
i can but it's i mean it was working
anyway how many nerf guns did you guys
break on this elliot's like three
keanu was going and training at that
place for six months or whatever yeah is
it just that you've done so much nerf
gunning i think you were just ready to
go you know it's just a lot of like
doing in your imagination over and over
it's watching john wick and then like
playing with the nerf gun pretending
i've got nothing to say bad about that i
mean maybe you should come and
choreograph one of my films jesus pretty
good
that would be amazing yeah so we're like
all right nerf guns are cool what if it
was uh jon snow and game of thrones like
john wick
oh what took his swede off yes it's not
that hard really people make it harder
than it needs to be i mean you're good
at the choreography but you just need to
show what's going on i mean it's as
simple as that if you've got enough time
to train and enough time in the day to
do as many takes as you need to get the
shot right then you can do it i mean
that's what made jackie chan so great i
watched him do 38 takes of of one
movement because he had the time to do
that because jackie chan a lot of these
lower budget films that i work on we
don't have the time we've just got to go
through it so how much time did you have
for this please say one week two days
one of the things that that you see with
a lot of action stuff is that the
cinematography is also something that
needs to go hand in hand yeah right like
if both of those things are firing on
all cylinders i think it has a very
detrimental effect you know it's still
very much you know it's a dance on top
of all the other things going on and if
you can just take the time to get those
rhythms right and get them tight and
close so they're all hitting correctly
just under crank it a little bit
so i promised you that if jackie chan
was on this show i would never ask for
you to subscribe ever again jackie chan
has not been on the show yet so consider
subscribing to quarter crew
get back
look out there i am flaring my nostrils
getting ready for the inevitable
i didn't do that let's see the back pad
yep
andre olofsky was the heavyweight
champion in the ufc for a long time and
he's a beast man great to work with
normally he would punch me in the face
and be like this far away but we filmed
this in 3d because of the depth
perception you're gonna have to be this
close to your face
but he had good control actually he was
accurate enough to do that yeah he was
good was that a wire pull into the wall
there yes so that's not that that's not
me either you see we've got a dent in
the wall already from the previous tank
yes
[Laughter]
it's things like this that here where
you've got to really rehearse it well
because you've only got one take of
smashing into that i put my hands up too
soon to be honest i was anticipating the
kick my bad but you know we all made
mistakes you know when somebody throws a
hit and you have to block it sure you're
not putting 100 in it but you're making
contact on your forearms what are you
dealing with when you're you know doing
the fight and blocking all the time how
do you not just like break your forearms
or have your forearms get destroyed
that's the martial arts you see if you
come from traditional martial arts like
taekwondo part of the training is to be
with your partner and he's throwing a
punch at you and you're blocking it and
doing your techniques that repetition of
bone on bone is building up the strength
of your forearms a guy who's a real
martial artist they're going to be okay
but they need someone that hasn't find
someone like me that's done it for so
many years it's gonna hurt them
yeah and that's just part of the gig to
be honest i've done a few uh films with
some real fighters and i've caught them
in the corner doing this
that's what i'm talking about
this is the sort of thing that people
will forget to do you'll notice that the
camera is coming around to the other
side of the line because we know we need
to do the stun from the other side so
you know we're not just flipping to that
side we're getting the camera to come
across it's really smart it takes a lot
of coordination to be able to figure out
those moves i feel like the most
effective fight scenes consider the
camera to be like the third participant
in the fight absolutely inevitably if
you're working with a camera guy that
you've not worked with before an
operator if he hasn't done many fight
movies you've got to educate the game as
you're going through it and by the time
you finish the movie now he knows what
he's doing and so it would be great if
we could do another film
so when you can go into one of these
movies with a guy that you've worked
with before that's that's preferable you
got your prop baseball bats right and
they're soft we immediately just broke
them oh really and uh we didn't have any
replacements so when we've both got the
metal baseball bats we're actually
fighting with real wow baseball bats you
gotta watch out for the knuckles on
those yeah because you know we've got
two days to do this and the clock is
ticking and we haven't got the baseball
bats so i'm just going to use the real
baseball bats so this is my favorite
shot here because it all plays out and
then that looks like properly laughs
the next kick follows it and when you
can put all that together in one take it
ups the level of of the excitement of
the fight pulling a ufc fighter into a
film fight he's doing a great job of
selling when he gets hit yeah how did he
adjust like did he have any issues like
having to you know change his distances
to sell his hits he's very good he's
just good i've worked with some proper
fighters that really don't get it and he
got it you know he knows to make his
punches a bit wider and to sell them
when you're on the mitts doing your
routines that's essentially choreography
anyway you learn to remember
choreography
as you're remembering choreography on
the pants what's the biggest injury
you've taken uh while filming a scene i
mean nothing major but i pulled my back
badly on ninja too
i had to get doubled for it i never get
double for my fight scenes if i'm doing
a kick you know i want people to know
it's me doing it but at the same time
you don't want to wreck the film so i
had to do the rest of the movie with
this this pain in my back for the whole
time you know it's not nice doing a
physical job when
moving hurts yeah you know if you're
carrying an injury it just makes the
whole thing even harder
i think this is where i pulled my back
and started to tighten up as i went over
the table and so it's getting tighter
and tighter and then i spin that way and
then i spin the other way and then i
that's how i got my back so now my back
is done
but i'm still having to continue and i
literally can't lift my other leg up
this one was with the other leg but we
had to switch it
because i just couldn't do it the other
side you can see that i'm sort of
holding my back as i'm punching in there
i'm being a bit tender with myself you
are really selling it well for having a
back injury i feel like there's got to
be a constant pressure that's like
hanging over your head is if you screw
it up and you take a hit too hard you
are in trouble for it
you got the weight of the rest of the
entire production is sitting on your
shoulders to not screw it up exactly and
it's a game of odds isn't it i make a
lot of movies and they're all action
mostly so at some point
i'm going to be injured
just from a statistical standpoint yeah
right yeah it's a young man's game
no i'm doing okay i love my job and yeah
it's not easy and i do moan sometimes
but it's a privilege to be able to make
movies and i love action films you know
my agents are like you know we need to
get you doing some romantic comedies and
this and i'm like nah man i want to do
action films come on
if you have an action scene that you
think could impress scott that you may
have not seen before leave a suggestion
you're sitting around at home you're
watching this you're thinking hey maybe
i could do some punches and kicks well
guess what i got two pieces of advice
for you number one start stretching i
think that's probably fair right start
stretching number two check out scott
atkins channel scott deck is the art of
action you do deep dives you're talking
to people in the industry some of the
top martial artists stunt choreographers
stunt directors if you want to get into
this world you got surround stuff you
gotta immerse yourself and there's no
better place than scott's youtube
channel actually yeah if you do want to
learn about stress you can also go to my
channel because i have martial arts
tutorials i forgot about that
i teach you how to kick and how to be
flexible scott atkins youtube channel go
there
well scott thank you so much really
appreciate it freddie thank you guys
always a good time thanks for joining us
no problem thanks for having me niko
well i guess uh the rest of my day is
going to be boring now because this is
basically the pinnacle of my week i
considered briefly like you know like
will you like punch my hand or kick my
arm or something like that just to show
me like what the power looks like then
just be sitting here going like
the rest of the day we should do the
first kick that samo does on that guy
yeah yeah and you go volunteers with cut
to like 20 minutes later niko's coming
out with a michelin man's suit and the
full helmet
[Laughter]